imagine after a long wait you finally
get your hands on a covert testing kit
imagine you've been feeling ill and want
to know if you're okay
now imagine you're blind
it has no
uh markings on it and again this is a
cardboard box so um
you know boxes of band-aids have braille
on them now come on over inside the tent
for many disabled people the surgeon
testing has left them behind if you're
blind and one million people in the us
are then simply working out what to do
is a challenge there were testing
centers that were drive through only and
of course blind people don't drive
we do have as a matter of national
public policy the idea that people with
disabilities are supposed to be
integrated and included
so why is there nobody thinking about on
the front end before things
become a problem
pandemic restrictions were hard on
almost everyone but even more
complicated for those who are disabled
there is the americans with disabilities
act the law's intention that every
american has the same rights and
opportunities as everyone else it gives
people a sense of independence and
dignity during the pandemic we have seen
all 50 states
operationalize what's called crisis
standards of care and these are
standards that a hospital uses to
determine who gets access to treatment
in times of a shortage of
of medical resources
and so states have used disability as a
means of saying you know what your life
is not worth living it's not worth
saving
in fact one in four adult americans has
a disability
defined as a physical or mental
impairment that impacts a major life
activity
and long covert could see those numbers
rise dramatically you may be seeing
people with long covet who are
experiencing
things like fatigue reduced lung
capacity brain fog
as well as
individuals who have
had
significant stress and trauma throughout
the pandemic who are now having to
adjust to life with a psychiatric
disability
the white house has responded to
criticism and made some changes
including recommending to drug companies
that they make testing easily accessible
for everyone but things aren't going to
change overnight there will be a lag and
that means for people with disabilities
it's going to take longer to get back to
normal
alan fisher al jazeera at the white
house